fragen wir nach bei Johannes Hano in New
York Herr Hano die Sicherheitsbehörden
haben ja für heute in Manhattan quasi
Alarmstufe Rot ausgerufen auch wegen der
Erfahrungen mit dem Kapitol im Januar
2021 wie ist denn aktuell die Situation
auf den Straßen New Yorks
also es ist hier rund um das
Gerichtsgebäude ein Spektakel es gibt
hier relativ viele Leute die gekommen
sind um einen Blick auf Donald Trump zu
erhaschen den sie natürlich nicht
erhaschen können weil das alles durch
Hintertüren gelaufen ist also hier ankam
aber im Grunde genommen ist alles sehr
sehr friedlich es gibt so ein paar
hundert Demonstranten vielleicht die
sich gegenüber standen die haben sich
gegenseitig bewirbelt hier und da gibt's
eine Harke live aber im Grunde genommen
ist das alles sehr sehr friedlich die
Polizei hat das beste griff die wird
auch ziemlich entspannt muss man sagen
und ich glaube auch wenn hier jemand
Ärger machen will hätte hier New York
keine Chance in New Yorker Polizei hat
55 000 Polizistinnen und Polizisten
davon 35.000 in Uniform und man hat im
Vorfeld schon ganz klar gesagt wer
hierher kommen und Unruhe machen will
muss damit rechnen festgenommen und
verhaftet zu werden da würde man keine
Kompromisse machen ich glaube nicht dass
ihr irgendetwas passiert Donald Trump
der ist jetzt hinter mir im
Entschuldigung ja nein bitte bitte
nein nein also Donald Trump der ist
jetzt hinter mir im Gerichtsgebäude er
ist wohl gerade erkennungsdienstlich
behandelt worden ist hieß es wird wohl
kein Polizeifoto geben weil Donald Trump
so bekannt als gäbe so viele Fotos von
ihm das selbst wenn der flüchten würde
in jeder erkennen würde da bräuchte man
nicht noch ein extra Foto Fingerabdrücke
werden die müssen genommen werden das
sieht das Recht hier sofort und dann
wird ihm tatsächlich jetzt wohl in
diesem Minuten wo die Anklageschrift
vorgetragen und es wird erwartet dass er
danach eventuell ein kurzes Statement
abgeben wird es gibt eine Kamera die
zugelassen ist nicht im Gerichtssaal
selber sondern vorher im Vorjahr da ist
eine Kamera aufgestellt und er hat
eigentlich schon angedeutet dass er wohl
sprechen will wir haben gehört dass
seine anwältigen gesagt haben worauf
erachten soll wenn er spricht dass er
sich noch möglicherweise einer weiteren
Straftat schuldig macht denn er hat ja
in der Vergangenheit in verschiedenen
Tweets auch relativ eindeutig zu Gewalt
aufgerufen und das könnte die in dem
ganzen Verfahren hier nicht besonders
die nicht sein sollte er das machen aber
wir kennen alle Donald Trump der lässt
sich von niemanden stoppen und wir sind
mal gespannt was er da sagen wird
jeden Fall wird er dann danach
Entschuldigung dieses Livebild was ihr
ansprechen liegt uns bereits vor also
aus dem Foyer im Gerichtsgebäude sie
haben ja geschildert offenbar gibt es
was die Demonstranten angeht nicht die
große Gefahr nicht die große Beteiligung
vielleicht auch die im Vorfeld
vorausgesagt wurde aber wir konnten auch
auf den Live-Bildern vom Hubschrauber
sehen es gibt ein riesiges Interesse der
Medien an dem Vorgang wie sieht es denn
mit den Interesse der Amerikaner selbst
aus wie groß ist das Interesse der
Amerikaner vielleicht sogar außerhalb
New Yorks an diesem Verfahren
also das Interesse hier in Amerika in
der ganzen Welt ist erst muss man sagen
gigantisch ich habe sowas selten erlebt
so viel Medien an einem Ort das ist
wirklich schon ziemlich beeindruckend
was sie aufgefahren worden das muss ich
sagen aber auch hier in Amerika die
letzten Tage rund um die Uhr wurde
darüber berichtet jeder Millimeter jede
Bewegung des ehemaligen Präsidenten
wurde hier mit Live Kameras aufgenommen
das war gestern sogar gegen so weit dass
man Hubschrauber in der Luft hatte als
das Flugzeug von Donald Trump hier in
laganja gelandet ist man hatte Boote auf
dem äh ist River um jeden Millimeter
dieses Fluges die Landung alles zu
knabbern also das Interesse ist
riesengroßes wird hier gibt wahnsinnig
viele Diskussionen darüber was ihn
bevorstehen könnte aber eins muss noch
mal ganz klar sagen niemand kann das
wirklich sagen im Moment denn die
Anklageschrift ist bislang noch nicht
bekannt der sein früherer Anwalt wurde
für ein ähnliches Vergehen zum mehreren
Jahren Haft schon verurteilt von einem
Bundesgericht hier und in dieser
damaligen an der Anklageschrift und auch
in dem Urteil Jesus dass er angestiftet
worden sei von Individuum eins und das
war ganz klar Donald gegen den konnte
man damals nicht vorgehen weil der
Präsident war da gibt es hier so eine
Regel dass man gegen Präsidenten
strafrechtlich nicht ermitteln kann und
der Anwalt von seinem früheren Anwalt
von Michael Cohen der hat gestern gesagt
es ist die Zeit der Gerechtigkeit
gekommen es kann nicht sein dass der
Handlanger ins Gefängnis geht und der
Auftraggeber ungeschoren davonkommen
dann sind wir mal gespannt auf die
Anklageschrift die Staatsanwaltschaft
hat gesagt dass sie ungefähr um 15:30
Uhr unserer Zeit also 21:30 Uhr
deutscher Zeit hier ein Statement
abgeben will eine Pressekonferenz gehen
will und dann wissen wir mehr ja und
wenn diese Anklage dann verlesen ist
Trump dann wieder nach Florida abgereist
ist kann man jetzt schon absehen wie ist
denn dann mit dem Verfahren in New York
weitergeht
also erstmal im Moment gerade gehört
seine Anwälte wollen wohl versuchen dass
dieses Verfahren von aus New York
abgezogen wird und möglicherweise in
anderen Bundesstaat verlegt wird das ist
eine Verzögerungstaktik weil das ist
sehr unwahrscheinlich dass der Richter
das zulassen wird dann wollen seine
Anwälte wohl versuchen
die ganze das ganze Verfahren zu wissen
wie es heißt also niederzulegen das sind
den Richter dazu aufzufordern
niederzulegen wegen Verfahrensfragen und
Verjährungsfristen und so weiter aber
auch da gehen wir davon aus dass das
nicht passieren wird das kann sich aber
noch über Wochen hinziehen bis dann eine
Entscheidung kommt und selbst wenn der
Richter dann sagt nein das Verfahren
findet hier in New York statt dann muss
eine Jury ausgewählt werden das kann
sich auch wiederum über Wochen hinziehen
also wir rechnen nicht damit dass das
vor dem Sommer wahrscheinlich sogar erst
Ende Sommer zu einem ersten
Verhandlungstag hier in New York kommt
Johannes Hannover
ich sage danke für Ihre Zeit